ད་ཁ་ཕྱེ་ག ག་འདྲས་ཕྱེ་ག
ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡིན། ཚང་མ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད་བས།
ཨ་ཚེ། ཁྱེད་རང་ག་རེ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽ཡོད།
ཨ། པགས་པ་བཤུ་གི་ཡོད། རྩེད་མོ།
བཤུ་ཐུབ་༼གི་༽མི་འདུག བསྟན་ད།
པགས་པ་བཤུ་གི་ཡོད།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། ཁ་ཕྱེས་ཚར་ཡིན། ཕྱེས་ཚར་ཡིན།
དང་པོ་༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽རེད་འདུག
དང་པོ་དེ་བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
ག་བར་འདུག་འདི།
འདི་མེ་ཏོག་རེད།
འདི་ཁང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)འདི་མེ་ཏོག མེ་ཏོག་གཉིས།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། སྒེའུ་ཁུང་གཉིས། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
ཤེལ་སྒོ་གསུམ། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
ཤེལ་སྒོ་གཅིག ཤེལ་སྒོ་གཉིས། ཤེལ་སྒོ་གསུམ། སྒེའུ་ཁུང།
སྒེའུ་ཁུང་གཅིག སྒེའུ་ཁུང་གཉིས།
སྒེའུ་ཁུང་གསུམ། སྒེའུ་ཁུང་བཞི། སྒེའུ་ཁུང་ལྔ། སྒེའུ་ཁུང་དྲུག ༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྒེའུ་ཁུང་བདུན།
སྒེའུ་ཁུང། སྒོ་རེད། འདི།
སྒོ་གཅིག སྒོ་གཉིས། སྒོ་གསུམ།
འོ་་་
འདི།
ལྗ་སྨུག
ག་རེ་འདུག་ལབ་ན།
ཨ། འདི། འདི་་་
གད་སྙིགས་བླུག་ས། གད་སྙིགས་བླུག་ས་འདི་ལ།
འདི་ལ། གད་སྙིགས།
གད་སྙིགས་བླུགས་ཡིན།
གད་སྙིགས་བླུག་ས་རེད།
ང་གཉིས་གཙུག་ལག་ཁང་ལ། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
དེ་རིང་ང་ཚོ་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་འགྲོ་ཚར་ཡིན།
དེ་ནས་ང་ཚོ་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་ཡག་པོ་འགྲོ་ཡིན། ཞོགས་པ་ཆུ་ཚོད་ལྔ་པ་ལ།
དགོང་དག་ཆུ་ཚོད་ལྔ་པ་ལ།
འ་་་
འོ་་་་ནང་འཐུང་གི་འདུག
འདི་ལ། འདི་ལ།
འདི་འདི་ལ། གཞན་པ་གླེང་སྐོར་མཐོང་གི་འདུག
རང་ཕ་ལ་ཕལ་ཕྱོགས་ལ་ཡོད་རེད།
འགྲོ།
བསྟན་ད་ལབ་ད།
ཨ་ཅག
འགྲོ་ད། སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ།
ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽(ར)། ཨ་མ་གིས།
བག་ལེབ་བཟོས་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽ཚལ་བཟོས་རེད། ཚལ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། པ་ལགས་གིས་ཙྭ་མི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽ཤེལ་སྒོ་མི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽ཤེས་སྒོ་མི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
པ་ལགས་གིས་དེབ་དཀར་པོ་མི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད། བསིལ་ལྷམ་མི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
པ་ལགས་གིས་༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)ཚལ་མི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། པ་ལགས་གིས་(ར)། པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽༼ར་༽ཚལ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
ཤ་མོ་འདུག་ལབ་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྒེའུ་ཁུངས་འདུག་ལབ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
ཤིང་ཏོག་འདུག་ལབ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽རྔན་པ་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། དང་པོ་ཡི་གེ་འབྲི་༼ཡ་༽རེད།
དེ་ནས་(ར)།
དེ་ནས་ཤེལ་སྒོ་བལྟ་རེད།
ད་(ར)། ད་རྐུབ་བཀྱག
ང་གཅིག་རག་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)།
སྒེའུ་ཁུང་དེ།
ད་ག་རེ་བྱེད་ག
ཆགས་མི་འདུག་ག
ད་ག་འདྲས་བྱེད་ད། ག་འདྲས་བྱེད་ག ད་(ར)།
ད་ར་་ཅོག་ཙེ་ཕྱེས་སོང་།
ད་ཅོག་ཙེ་བྱས།
ཅོག་ཙེ་གྱིས། ད་ར་ད་མེ་ཏོག་བཞག
མེད་ད།
ད་ར་འ་་་་ག་རེ་བྱེད་་་་་
ད་(ར)། ད་ར་ནང་བཟོ་༼ཡ་༽རེད། ནང་བྱས་ཨན་ནཝ
ར་
ད་(ར)། འདི་གྱིས།
འདི།
ག་བ་ཁྱེད་རང་སླེབས་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས།
ག་བར་རི་མོ།
ག་བ། ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽རེད་༼ཞག༽
རེད་༼ཞག༽ རེད་འདུག ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽རེད་༼ཞག༽
ད་ཆགས་སོང་། ད་(ར)། ད་འདི། ཆགས་སོང་།
ད་ར་འདི།
ལྗངས་ཁུ་འདི། འདི།
དངོས་གནས།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽རེད་༼ཞག༽
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽རེད་༼ཞག༽ འདི་ལྟ་ད།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽མ་རེད་༼ཞག༽ ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽མ་རེད་༼ཞག༽ ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽མ་རེད་ཤག ག་འདྲས་རེད་༼ཞག༽་ལབ་དགོས་བས། འདི་འདྲས་རེད་༼ཞག༽
ངས་ག་འདྲས་བྱེད་དགོས་
དེ་ནས། དེ་ནས་འདི།
འདི།
དེ་རེད་༼ཞག༽ དེ་རེད་༼ཞག༽ དེ་རེད་༼ཞག༽
དེ་ལ་རེད་འདུག རེད་༼ཞག༽ རེད་འདུག དེ་ནས།
ག་བ་བསྟན་ད། འདི།
འདི་འདི་ལ།
འདི་ག་བ་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས། དེ་གཅིག་གྱིས་ད།
དེ་(ར)། དེ་ག་བར་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས། ཕལ་རྒྱུགས་ཏིག་ཙ་སྒུགས་ཤ། འདི་ག་བར་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས
འདི། མ་རེད་ཏིག་ཙ་སྒུགས་ཨ།
ཨ་འདྲས་གཅིག རེད་འདུག
རེད་༼ཞག༽ རེད་༼ཞག༽ རེད་༼ཞག༽
རེད་༼ཞག༽
ད་དེ་བཟོ། དང་པོ་དེ་བཟོ་༼ཡ་༽རེད། འདི་དཀར་པོ་དེ་༼ཞག༽་ཡ་རེད།
དཀར་པོ་གཉིས། འདི་་་
ཧ་གོ་མ་སོང་། འདི། འདི་ལ་རེད་༼ཞག༽
འདི། འདི་ལ་གཅིག
འདི། འདི་ལ། འདི་འདི་ལ།
འདི་འདུག་ག བཟོ་དགོས་ཤོག ཤོག རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་གི་ཡོད།
འདི། འདི་ག་བར་རེད་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས། འདི་ལ་འདུག འདི་ལ་རེད་༼ཞག༽
འདི་འདྲས་རེད། འདི་ལ་རེད།
རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ། ང་ཆེན་པོ་ཆགས་སོང་།
འདི་(ར)།
ཨ་ཅག ཨ་ཅག་ག་བར་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་དགོས་རེད།
འདི་ག་བ།
འདི། འདི་ལ།
ག་འདྲས་སྒྲིགས་ག
འདི་འདི་ལ།
གཞན་པ་འདི་ལ། དཀར་པོ་འདི་འདི་ལ་རེད་༼ཞག༽ གཞན་པ་དེ།
སྒྲིགས་ད།
སླེབས་༼གི་༽འདུག
ད་དེ་ནས་འདི་རེད།
འདི། འདི་ལ།
འདི་འདྲས་སེ། འདི་འདྲས་བྱེད།
མི་འདུག ག་འདྲས་ལབ་དགོས་བས། ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽སེ། ཨ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ག་འདྲས་རེད། ག་འདྲས་རེད་ལབ་དགོས་བས། འདི་འདྲས་སེ།
ང་ཚོང་ཁང་ལ་འགྲོ་ག ཨ།
དེ་ནས། འདི། འདི་ལ་འདུག འདི་ལ།
འདི་རེད་འདུག་གས། འདི་རེད་༼ཞག༽ འདི་འདི་ལ་འདུག
འདི་གཅིག་བྱས་(ར)། ར།
འདི་བྱས་(ར)།
ཨ་(ར)། འདི་གཅིག་བྱས།
འདི་མར་བཞག ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽རེད་༼ཞག༽་ཧ་གོ་སོང་ང་།
ད་འདི་ལ། ད་ག་བར་འདུག་ལབ་དགོས་བས། འདི་ལ།
འདི་གཅིག་བྱས་(ར)།
ད་འདི། འདི་ལ། མ་རེད་འདི་ལ། ད་འདི།
འདི་གཅིག་བྱས་(ར)། ད་ཚར་སོང་། ད་ག་བ།
ད་ག་བ། ག་བ། ག་བ།
འདི་བརླགས་ཚར་༼ཞག༽
ཨ། འདི་ལ་འདུག་ག
འདི་ལ་གཅིག རེད་འདུག་གས། ད་ཚར་སོང་།
པར་(ར)། སྦང་ལབ་༼གི་༽མ་རེད།
༼སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ནང་ལ་ཡོད་(བ)། ནང་ལ་སླེབས་སོང་ད།
ཤེལ་སྒོ་དེ་(ར)།
ག་རེ་བྱས་པ་རེད་ལབ་པ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
ར། ནང་དེ་(ར)། ནང་དེ་ག་རེ་བྱས་པ་རེད་ལབ་རེད།
མེ་ཏོག་ག་རེ་བྱས་པ་རེད། ཤེལ་སྒོ་དེ་ག་རེ་བྱས་པ་རེད་ལབ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། སྨན་ཁང་ལ་ཁྲིད་རེད་(ད)།བསྡད་ས་ག་རེ་བྱས་བཤིག་པ་རེད་ལབ་རེད་(ད)་ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽(ར)།
དེ་ནས་(ར)།
དེ་ནས། བཤད་སོང་།
༼སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་༽ཨ་མ་༼གིས་༽ཞི་མི་ཡིན་ལབ་རེད། ཁྱོད་ཞི་མི་མ་རེད་ལབ་རེད། ངའི་པུ་གུ་གྲོག་མོ་ཡིན་པ་ལབ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ག་རེ་བྱས་པ་རེད་ལབ་རེད་རྒན་ལགས་གིས།
སྡིག་པ་
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཐུག་པ་དེ་ག་རེ་ལབ་རེད། ཐུག་པ་ཞིམ་པོ་མི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
ང་ཞི་མི་ཡིན་ལབ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ངས་(ར)།
ཁུ་སིམ་བྱས་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁ་ལག་ཟ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ཞོ་ཟ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
རྔན་པ་ཟ་༼ཡ་༽ཡོད་་མ་རེད། སྣུམ་བྱུག་རེད་(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
ཆུ་བླུགས་༼ཨ་ནས་༽གཟུགས་པོ་བཀྲུས་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽འཁྱགས་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽བཙོན་ཁང་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།པ་ལགས་གིས་ལབ་ལེབ་དེ་ཪོགས་པ་བྱས་རེད།
པ་ལགས་གིས་ཡག་པོ་བྱེད་༼གི་༽འདུག་ལབ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡང་བསྐྱར་སྟོད་ཕད་ཁུར་འགྲོ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)ཡང་བསྐྱར་གྲང་གི་རེད།
ར།
ཤིང་ཏོག་ཁེར་ད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད།
ཕྱི་ལོགས་ལ་གཅིག་འགྲོ་རེད།
ང་ཚོ་༼ར་༽Bhagsu ལ་འགྲོ་ཚར་(ར)།
ཆུ་བརྒལ་ག་ལ་འགྲོ་ཚར་(ར)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽རག་མ་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་ཚོ་པ་ལགས་གིས་རྩེད་མོ་ཉོ་གི་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ཨ་ཅག་གིས་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར
རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཉོ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ཁ་བརྟགས་ལ་ག་ཚོད་རེད་ལབ་རེད། ༡༣༠ རེད་ལབ་རེད།
ཤིང་ཏོག་ཉོ་མ་རེད། པ་ལགས་གིས་(ར)། པ་ལགས་གིས་ཆུ་ཉོ་ས་རེད
པ་ལགས་གིས་ག་རེ་ཟིམ་དགོས་རེད།
པ་ལགས་གིས་ཀུ་ཤུ་ཉོ་རེད།
ཀུ་ཤུ་ད་རྒུན་འབྲུམ་ཉོས་པ་རེད།
སྐོར་ར་བརྒྱབ་རེད།
ཀུ་ཤུ་དེ་ཟ་རེད། ཀུ་ཤུ་ལ་འབུ་ཡོད་རེད།
རྒུན་འབྲུམ་ལ་འབུ་ཡོད་མ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། སུ་གང་གཅིག་ལ་འབུ་ཡོད་མ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། རྐུབ་བཀྱག་དྲུད་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽མིག་ལྟ་རེད། བརྙན་འཕྲིན་ལ་མིག་ལྟ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽མོ་ཊ་བཏང་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཤིང་ཏོག་འགྲོ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)སྒེའུ་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽བསྡད་ས་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽Bagsu ལ་འགྲོ་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཆུ་བརྒལ་ག་ལ་འགྲོ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)མོ་ཊ་བཏང་རེད་ཡང་བསྐྱར་རེད། དེ་ནས་ནང་ལ་འགྲོ། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽།
ཡང་བསྐྱར་གཅིག་(ར)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)ཤིང་སྡོང་ཡོད་རེད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽Bagsu ལ་ཡང་བསྐྱར་འགྲོ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། ཉལ་་་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽སྒྲུང་རྫོགས་
ང་པ་ལགས་ལ་
པ་ལགས་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ག་འགྲོ་ལབ་སོང་།
གོག་ཚར་སོང་།
གྲོགས་པོ་རེད།
དཔའ་སངས་གཡུ་མཚོ་གིས་ང་ལ་རྩེད་་མོ་རྩེ་གི་རེད།
དེ་ནས་ང་(ར)།
དེ་ནས་ང་(ར)། པུ་གུ་བསིལ་ལྷམ་ཆུང་ཆུང་གོན་རེད།
པུ་གུ་ཆུང་ཆུང་བསིལ་ལྷམ་གོན་རེད།
ད་ལྟ་གོན་རེད།
བཏང་མ་སོང་།